hey this is pressure Hawker a miser can
make one cigarette from five cigarette
butts what is the most number of
cigarettes
the miser can make from 1,000 cigarette
butts while you're working on this
problem I'm going to pose another
problem the number 100 has two trailing
zeros the number ends in two zeros the
number thirty thousand twenty has one
trailing zero because it ends in one
zero the number 1000 34 has no trailing
zeros it does not end in a zero
how many trailing zeros are there in the
number 1000 factorial give these
problems a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for the
solutions we'll get started with the
miser every five cigarette butts he can
craft into a new cigarette so we can
divide the number of cigarette butts by
five to get the number of cigarettes he
can make he starts out with the thousand
cigarette butts so that means if you
divide that by five he can craft 200
cigarettes and some people think this is
the answer but if you think a little
creatively he can now smoke these 200
cigarettes to get 200 more cigarette
butts from those 200 cigarette butts he
can then craft another 40 cigarettes why
stop there he can smoke these 40
cigarettes to get 40 more cigarette
butts he can then craft another 8
cigarettes out of that and if he smokes
these 8 cigarettes well the number 5
goes into this one more time will you
get the total number of cigarettes
the miser can make by adding these
numbers up we have 200 plus 40 plus 8
plus 1 which gets us the answer of 249
cigarettes so what does this have to do
with factorials and trailing zeros the
first observation is that the number of
trailing zeros in a number corresponds
to the number of time
it has a factor of 10 10 is equal to 2
times 5 if we count the number of
factors of 2 and the number of factors
of 5 then we'll have the number of
factors of 10 now notice that every
other number is an even number which has
a factor of 2 whereas only every 5th
number has a factor of 5 so we're gonna
have a lot more factors of 2 than there
are factors of 5 so when we're creating
these factors of 10 the limiting reagent
is the number of factors of 5 so we can
count the number of factors of 10 by
counting the number of factors of 5 in
1000 for ian's we can do that by
counting the number of factors of 5 in
the numbers 1 through 1,000 so we take
the maximum number and divided by 5 to
get the number of factors of 5 there are
because the factor 5 happens every 5
terms so from the numbers 1 to 1000 we
divide by 5 to get that there are 200
factors of 5 every 5th number
contributes 1 factor of 5 to the power
of 1 but why stop there
if we look at every 25th number we get
one more factor of 5 so we then get that
there are 40 numbers which have the
factor of 5 squared we get one more 40
more factors of 5 out of this we can
then divide by 5 one more time this will
give us that there are 8 more terms
which have factors of 5 to the cubed
this is 125 if we go one more time
we can only end up with one more term
this will have a number of factor of 625
to get the total number of factors we
count up these terms 200 plus 40 plus 8
plus 1 and that gets us to the answer
that there are 249 trailing zeros in
1,000 for you and it's really cool that
we can figure out the number of zeros in
this really immensely big number without
actually having to do the calculation of
figuring out what the exact answer is we
can simply count the number of factors
of 5
did you figure out these problems thanks
for watching this video please subscribe
to my channel I make videos on map and
game theory you can catch from my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media app fresh
talker and if you liked this video
please check out my books there are
links in the video description